thank you
1 Timothy 4 verse 12.
let no one despise you for your youth
but set the Believers an example in
speech in conduct
in love in faith in purity
1 Corinthians 16 verse 13.
Be watchful
stand firm in the faith act like men be
strong let all that you do be done in
love
1 Corinthians 15 58.
therefore my beloved Brothers
be steadfast immovable always abounding
in the work of the Lord knowing that in
the Lord your labor is not in vain
1 Peter 5 5.
you who are younger
be subject to the elders clothe
yourselves all of you with humility
toward one another for God opposes the
proud
but gives Grace
to the humble
1 Timothy 4 verse 8.
for wild bodily training is of some
value
godliness is of value in every way as it
holds promise for the present life and
also for the life to come
Psalm 118 Verse 8.
it is better to take refuge in the Lord
than to trust in man
Galatians 1 verse 10.
for am I now seeking the approval of man
or of God
or am I trying to please man if I were
still trying to please man I would not
be a servant of Christ
Joshua 1 verse 9.
have I not commanded you be strong and
courageous
do not be frightened and do not be
dismayed for the Lord your God is with
you
wherever you go
James 1 19.
know this my beloved Brothers
let every person be quick to hear
slow to speak
slow to anger
for the anger of man does not reduce the
righteousness of God
Psalm 119 verse 9.
how can a young man keep his way pure
by guarding it according to your word
James 1 verse 2.
count it all joy my brothers when you
meet Trials of various kinds for you
know that the testing of your faith
produces steadfastness
Proverbs 27 verse 17.
iron sharpens iron and one man sharpens
another
[Music]
2 Corinthians 4 16.
so we do not lose heart though our outer
self is wasting away our inner self is
being renewed day by day
Romans 12 verse 2.
do not be conformed to this world
[Music]
but be transformed by the renewal of
your mind that by testing you may
discern what is the will of God
what is good and acceptable and perfect
1 Timothy 6 11.
as for you o man of God
flee these things pursue righteousness
godliness
Faith love steadfastness and gentleness
fight the good fight of the faith
1 Peter 5 8.
be sober minded Be watchful
your adversary the devil prowls around
like a roaring lion
seeking someone to devour
resist him firm in your faith knowing
that the same kinds of suffering are
being experienced by your Brotherhood
throughout the world
Psalm 118 Verse 6.
the Lord is on my side
I will not fear
what can man do to me
Deuteronomy 8 verse 3.
and he humbled you and let your hunger
and fed you with Mana which you did not
know
nor did your fathers know
that he might make you know that man
does not live by bread alone
but man lives by every word
that comes from the mouth of the Lord
[Music]
scientists 2 verse 7.
show yourself in all respects to be a
model of good works
and in your teaching show Integrity
dignity and sound speech
that cannot be condemned
so that an opponent may be put to shame
having nothing evil to say about us
1 Corinthians 13 verse 11.
when I was a child I spoke like a child
I thought like a child I reasoned like a
child
when I became a man
I gave up childish ways
foreign
37 verse 23 the steps of a man are
established by the Lord
when he Delights in his way
[Music]